Europe's nationalist wave has arrived in Spain.
The Vox party secured 12 seats in Andalusia
- a region with a high rate of both unemployment
and migration.The party's president is confident
they can now take their regional gains to
the national level:
Andalusians once again have made history.
They have shaken off 36 years of Socialist
regimes, paving the way for the rest of Spain
by saying that it is possible, and even easy,
to do the same in the rest of the country.
The election has severly weakened the governing
socialists.
Although they secured the most seats, they
fell short of a majority.
Despite this, they're vowing to stop the rise
of the far-right.
An alternative for Andalusians does not mean
that our government will become a reflection
of this right-wing party, which is xenophobic
and justifies violence against women and amongst
citizens.
Ever since the end of Francisco Franco's dictatorship
in 1975, the socialists have dominated politics
in the region.
But Sunday's election has shaken the status
quo.The ballot was the first major test for
Prime Minister Pedro Sanchez, who leads a
minority government.
And with a host of elections coming up in
20-19, Spain's socialists face
a crucial year.